hello everyone
welcome to the active inference live
stream
this is active inference live stream
10.2
it is december 15 2020 and we are
really excited to be having this
discussion with all of you
today welcome to the active inference
lab everyone
we are an experiment in online team
communication
learning and practice related to active
inference
you can find us at our website on
twitter
at email our youtube channel or our
public cubase team and username
this is a recorded and archived live
stream so please provide us with
feedback so that we can improve on our
work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and as far as video
etiquette for live streams
remember to mute if there's noise in
your background raise your hand so that
we can hear from everyone on the stack
and use respectful speech behavior
just as a quick little announcement
slash point of process
all the rest of the meetings for the
rest of 2020 are at 7 30 to 9 a.m
pst last week we had 10.1 on the script
paper and today we're having a follow-up
discussion on the scripts paper 10.2
and then for the final two weeks of
december we're going to be reading the
paper sophisticated
affective inference so check out the
dates and um
contact us if you want to participate in
these final discussions
or in 2021 or if you have an idea for an
event that we could do on the active
stream
we have a lot to announce coming up soon
and one good place to stay apprised of
that would be
on our website where you can find this
call for a collaboration link
so if you go to activeinference.org and
check out this aweber link
you'll see some information about
collaborating in 2021
on the live stream and on other really
cool projects
great so today in active 10.2
we are going to start with introductions
and warm-ups
and then we're gonna go through 10.2
we're going to be talking about the
variational approach to scripps paper
that we've been talking about for the
last week as well and check out 10.0
if you want some context and check out
10.1 for
last week's awesome discussion we'll go
through the aims claims
abstract and roadmap today and then
there's some new sets of questions about
types of scripts and how the scripts
look
and other questions and then we'll um
look through the figures which is
something that we
brought up last time and next week
there's going to be a different paper so
get in touch if you want to participate
all right thanks for that now on to the
intros and warm-ups so for the
introductions and warm-ups
let's introduce ourself by giving a
short
introduction or check-in and then
passing it to somebody
who hasn't spoken i'm daniel i'm
a postdoc in california and i
will pass it to blue
i am blue knight i am an independent
research consultant based out of new
mexico
and i will pass it to rj
my name is rj corday i'm on the east
coast of the united states
and i'm mostly doing research in
organizational dynamics intelligence
analysis and narrative warfare and i'll
pass it to shannon
if shannon's here
we'll come back to shannon uh alex then
uh thanks i'm alex i'm located
in moscow russia and i'm a researcher
in systems management school and i pass
it to sasha
hi i'm sasha i'm a graduate student
also in california and i study
neuroscience and development
and i will pass it to stephen
hello i'm stephen i'm based in toronto
in canada
i do a lot of work with participatory
theatre and
participatory development workshops and
i'm doing a practice-based phd
at the moment and i'm going to pass it
to
ivan
hello my name is ivan i'm based in
moscow
i'm interested in acting for
in case of system thinking
and i passed it to shannon shannon
cool well i think shannon will come back
online whenever
she's ready so for now we can just
continue on to the warm-up questions
for these questions feel free just to
raise your hand we're happy to
hear from anyone so one question since
many of you were here last week is what
is something that
you thought about differently after our
conversation
last week and so while people are
raising their hand
um i just really liked this
way of thinking about scripts and genres
for our encounters
and at the life trajectory level and at
the sort of sub
scene level what genre are we drawing
our scripts from rj
uh so after last week's conversation uh
what i ended up really thinking about is
what happens when
we lose our scripts so
it seems like scripts are are um
a framework for representing like like
how how we how we move through these
complex
social interactions um so what happens
when
say like in the spanish inquisition
where it was a process by which they
were actively trying to remove
scripts that people had um what happens
in the absence of them
when we tear them away so that that's
that's i've been thinking about that a
lot last week
interesting question blue
i've been thinking really a lot about um
like the transparency of active
inference versus like other types of
like deep learning and how they're kind
of a black box and really what
rj uh had said last week about how
active inference is more like a blanket
of black boxes i thought that that was
pretty cool and i've been like
kind of you know twirling that around in
my head for the last week
cool and it's almost like um if the
sentence oh go ahead sasha
um uh kind of the opposite of rj
for the last week i've been thinking uh
what's not a script
um and can there
be an absence of a script because um
we're we're just as apt to follow
another set of directions as we are
um the cultural set of directions that
we get for interactions
so um that's been kind of uh vexing
because it's similar to the problem with
um thinking about free energy and active
inference that once you see it
then you wonder like what's not in that
category
and um how do we
kind of draw the correct boundaries
around uh the definitions
of these terms because yeah once you see
scripts you really see it
around around you in every situation
yeah to your point there sasha it's like
if a
first-time ever social experience or a
very ritualized one
if the scripps concept can include both
of those as well as the internalist and
externalist concept
it's kind of like how many grains of
sand in a heap like how
reproducible or how strong does the
pattern of a social encounter have to be
before we're going to deem it scripts of
a certain kind
blue so to kind of to
piggyback on what you and sasha were
both saying like i've been thinking
about
like is maybe everything is a script
like is a chair
a script really like i mean a chair has
like a set role and like a thing we do
with it or it can
you know take on a new like script so
like what what about all of these like
objects in our everyday society really
like once you
once you see a script like what is not a
script like i i have a hard time like
you know unfolding that well it's like
the wood is
cheering you know the chair is a noun
but it's a it's a process and it was it
built and it will eventually not be a
chair
and so while it's chairing we can draw
a blanket you know put a seat cover on
it and use it
in the functional interface of being a
chair and so especially when things
become
um sufficiently compartmentalizable
or interfaceable so that they have a
functional way
of dealing with them instead of just
getting lost in the
becoming and unbecoming of chairs we can
start to think all right well yes that
is happening but also there's this
stable pattern
that i can sit on that's why we're
calling it a chair and so it's like this
emergence of reproducible function
and pattern out of continual becoming an
unbecoming
and so that is to the point with a lot
of discussions about the markov blanket
or the fristen blanket
whatever it ends up being in these
questions about ergodicity as well
like does everything by virtue of having
inputs and outputs
is everything going to be under this
umbrella or is this kind of umbrella
only going to be over things that have
um input output relationships of some
type
over some spatial or temporal scale
steven
i think this also made me think about
where sense making comes in
um and how this approach to scripts it
kind of
it helps extend the active inference
work with deontic queues
you know they talk about the traffic
lights and a lot of other things in the
models and this starts to extend
these sort of top-down cues into
narratives and stuff like that but
there's still
the the more existential kind of
participatory sense making and the kind
of
existential sense making processes which
are maybe
um they're still open to sort of somehow
integrate with this more
scripted kind of way of making sense of
the world so i think that's
that's something that i'm interested in
in
where do they start to sort of mesh or
override each other in different ways
cool all right let's go to the next
warm-up question
how could a different idea of scripts
relate to how we regulate the behavior
of ourselves and
others so depending on how somebody
thinks about scripts
how might they be likely to treat their
own behavior differently and how might
they
be likely or willing to engage in
different kinds of regulations of other
people's behavior
so let's just say that there's some prop
in a script
so something like a uh artifact or an
object
so if just like to rj's example about
wanting to uproot a script
so then you could say well you can't use
this symbol or you can't use this
combination of words
or we're not allowing anything from this
genre of script
and we're going to know it because it's
going to have this
style and so depending on how we
formalize these scripts
maybe in order to regulate other
people's
deployment of scripts we might take very
specific
um sub components like a certain set of
words or an artifact and then say well
this
is or isn't ruled in rj
uh yeah so so on this um uh
one one thing uh going going back to the
last question just what you kind of uh
stole the words out of me about what i
wanted to say which was
is a uh is a chair a script for wood
um but uh i i also want to know like on
this
is i i got to have a conversation
yesterday with eric sapp
from public democracy and a lot of the
stuff they've been doing
uh as i mentioned to you before dan is
like um
using uh like traditionally what would
be used for for advertising
uh for for for like public good so
uh what they've done in one case was was
be able to
uh use the same tools that they would
use to target advertising
to um uh target recent
people who have very recently picked up
a heroin addiction
um looking at their their behaviors
online be able to figure out that
they're
that they've recently picked up this
addiction or that they've very likely
had
and then give them on-ramps toward
treatment at the time when they are most
likely
um uh able to to move toward accepting
those types of treatments
they're they're not they're not very
deep into the addiction yet so
um i i brought up scripts to him uh and
we we talked a little bit about it
and it seems like their look at it is
like yeah it's it's almost like one if
if you can give people
the idea um that um they're using these
scripts and that they can change them
and that they're creating them in real
time or adapting to them in real time
then
um you kind of have the self-awareness
that can kind of help you
um uh moving down like we talked about
radicalization last week like if you're
aware
of of of the scripts that are in the
space maybe you can you can be
self-aware when you're using them
uh so i think that's one thing and then
um in addition like
recognizing when you're about to hit a
threshold where you're about to like
start using a script rather than just
some behavior which kind of ties to what
sasha was saying is like
at what point do we call something a
script so i'm not sure but but
anyway yep um it reminds me of the
gateway
idea like gateway drug or gateway
website or
gateway meme whatever it is it's like
using that metaphor it's like
whoa if you go through the gateway if
you pass through you're not coming back
it's all downhill from there
well that's one script it's a narrative
for how you could proceed through
different types of experiences
but could there be a sort of like
visitation metaphor it's like hey you're
gonna visit
this landia and then your family's still
gonna be waiting for you and they all
want you to become uh
safe and come home for example and then
that could be
a attractor that takes some of the same
setup
it's a similar genre at least in the
beginning of the movie but then
it goes a different way and so that
definitely is a
is a nice point there okay and then our
last warm-up question
what's something that you're still
wondering about or
something that you'd like to have
resolved by the end of today's
discussion
i really like this question also about
the
what's not a script or defining by
defining what isn't
another thing that wrote i wrote down to
ask about is the the transparency of the
concept is something that we'll probably
return to
many times and is it really more
transparent to
sub-compartmentalize it into a lot of
smaller black boxes or
are we doing something quite distinct
from that what else does anyone think
like
what could be a fun area to take this
script's
concept in or what could be somewhere
where we could go in the discussion
but if no thoughts here then no worries
because there's a bunch of
questions that will be asked in the
later stages so
good okay shannon i hope that you can
hear us or
rejoin when you can but
let's get into it and then anyone just
raise your hand when things come to you
and we'll go from there cool
so the paper that we are discussing this
week as with last week
is a variational approach to scripts and
we had
mao last week on the panel which was
great
the aims and claims of the paper we went
through those in 10.0
and heard it from the authors themselves
last week but the big question here is
about
unifying the study of scripts using the
active inference framework
in all of these different dimensions the
strong and the weak and the internal and
the external and
the social and the neural behavioral all
these different aspects of scripts
how are we going to reframe it within
the active inference framework and then
what would that do what would that give
us in terms of understanding or unique
predictions or explanations
in the abstract they also run through
this
notion that they're going to be
leveraging the resources of active
inference
to offer up a formal model of scripts
that's not just
a flowchart or a mind map or prose but
it's actually
a relationship amongst variables that
specifies how some of these
script uh variations like weak versus
strong
internal versus external can be
considered so we'll return to that in
the figures especially
and then in the road map we saw that
classic formula
with an introduction and then theory x
in this case script theory
and then active inference in section
three and then in the following section
a summation of theory x with active
inference
so that's the active inference account
of scripts
and this was an introductory work so
there's probably many
ways to follow down the rabbit hole for
a specific subtype of script or
other dimensions but um the main
dimensions
of variability in the scripts concept
that were highlighted by the authors
were this strong versus weak and
internalist versus externalist
so the strong scripts concept reflects
event sequences that are extremely
stereotyped or extremely
reproducible or um kind of like that
grand canyon
in the landscape it's like you're being
channeled along very strongly by a
specific
uh script whereas on the weak side we
see things that are
more probabilistic or potentially a
preference or bias or
more likely to go one way than another
but it isn't exactly pre-specified
and then on the y-axis we have this
internalist versus externalist
axis so the internalist perspective is
going to
look towards smaller things things that
are inside of the person like the brain
or the cells or computational things the
cells are doing
or something that the neurons are doing
in terms of secretion or firing or
electromagnetic rhythms whereas the
externalist perspective
as it just would sound like is thinking
about things that are
external to the focal agents so that
would be
the relationships in the social network
as well as quote
society and even broader things like the
ecosystem
cool so those were all things that we'd
talked about in the previous
weeks and now i want to
raise some new questions about scripts
relationships and
active inference so the first question
is
how might scripts of different kinds
whether
the strong weak internal external or
some other feature that people are
wondering about
how might they conceptualize of social
relationships
and in this case just for reference i'm
thinking of this social network on the
right
there's two blue nodes let's just think
of them as our focus
relationship so now we're moving beyond
the individual as the focal system
let's think about the edge and the
relationship as the focal system
and then seeing that edge in context of
a broader
network so what might anybody think
about
um how would scripts conceptualize
of social relationships and then i'll
just throw up the second question too
which is
how could active inference add depths
and tools or context to the social
scripts
concept
any thoughts from any domain are good
steven i might be curious
like to hear about from a practice side
how
how do we bring these ideas and then
make them like tangible and experienced
yeah i mean i i think this is this is
actually where this scale question
becomes kind of
kind of it becomes a challenge right
because as we're trying to net map
things out
um with social networks so there's a lot
of social network or participatory
inference mapping is one process which
is quite useful for looking at
and trying to understand how we relate
to each other's stories and experiences
in our network
but the question becomes is um
how do we relate this
um this kind of perspective we try to
take on stuff
with the scripts we use and then come
back to well how much of those scripts
are just manifestations
of embodied inactive ecological
behavior and we've kind of raiified them
so i i suppose um it becomes this
we we it's very much i think there's a
kind of a um
a situated um way
that we we kind of reenact or
recapitulate this whole thing depending
on
the discussion so you know like if
you're all sitting around a table
like in that board meeting where people
are putting together pictures of a
puzzle
they might be working with the scripts
of how they should
um assemble their perspectives
and then you've got someone in a who's
performing in a ritual
and it might be much more about how they
need to hold themselves
as a person so i think there's something
quite interesting that this whole
scripts thing
raises in terms of of the scale
question and i suppose that's partly why
you know
maxwell sort of ends up working a lot in
here as well because i think it ties
back to the question
of what scale is the script happening at
and that has a big impact when you try
to then
talk to people in a practice context
because
if you're working with a community or an
organization or
strategic strategy levels
doing strategic foresight they they may
be having their own kind of
um scripts that shape their
social practices in that kind of domain
so i think this is
this is kind of interesting what you
just
said there it reminds me of uh two
people like looking at a river
and they're seeing different things
they're seeing different scripts for the
river there's no disagreement about what
the river is doing
but one person looks at it and says yep
at the fork it goes left
and the other person says it goes with
the flow and today it's going left
and so in that sense um they're seeing
different scripts but they're not
disagreeing about what actually is
happening and so
it's like there's multiple concepts that
are being projected
onto the observables and then there's
the story about those two people
and how they reconcile their
perspectives by the riverbank
and so yes the scripps concept does seem
to apply everywhere
but maybe to begin to chisel away at
what isn't a script
i would say a chair could be a prop but
i don't think a chair has a model
where it is actually in agents doesn't
have agency
it's not an active entity in the script
though it can be
mobilized by actors in a way that a prop
can be can become
enlivened but it isn't with a generative
model of that situation
rj yeah i was going to say that the
chair
the chair is an object that can be a
part of a script but but
it i don't think it can it's not a
script itself and it can't
act out any scripts right because it's
not it's not an actor
um uh uh unless maybe
you know going out there it's like maybe
if it were a mechanical chair of some
kind
like a massage chair then it has been
script that has been encoded
by it by some other actor um but yeah
sasha and then stephen
okay that was a plot twist with the
massage chair
but perhaps the ability to
participate in a script does that does
that imply that
um you're able to respond differently in
different situations
because uh a chair will always be
chairing
um but an individual
or a participat yep participator in a
script
um they can change uh
based on the context and the kind of
script that they're participating in
so maybe that's a key aspect of being a
participator in a script
stephen yeah i think this chair is quite
an interesting
example like in theater they often work
with masks
and the mask they might be so bringing
this back to the bodies like there's
there's something about the mask and
identity
and taking off a mask and i've really
thought about this before but i don't
know say a throne compared to another
chair
could the throne almost be coated with a
mask
you know i mean it starts to have an
identity and it's like
you know so i mean a red nose is
basically the smallest mask you can wear
it's basically become a clown
but they're all this work we don't tend
to do much with masks but if you go back
to
sort of indigenous cultures everyone was
working with masks you know
um so there's something interesting in
is there something about the script
which is about how we
broadcast and receive through this part
of the body thanks
rj uh yeah no no
um bouncing off what's steven's saying
um so one one of the things uh when i
first
read the paper i talked to you about the
standard like immediately after reading
the paper i think actually
was um that uh if you look at
uh there's a common rituals between
north american indians
nordic cultures african like all over
the place where where
um what happens is there's uh it's
either
dances something along those lines where
you use animal masks
and act out the scripts
that those animals use it's really
important especially for you know like
uh
so i i brought up to you dan one point
the bear uh in particular
because a bear's an animal that has a
set of of scripts that you can identify
that it's using um and
and if you don't have experience
um you know knowing like reading their
behavior then you're more than likely
going to get hurt or put yourself in a
really dangerous situation so like
um park services in north america
routinely make the point
that almost all negative bearing
counters happen because
people don't know how to interact with
the bear they run
um they they're they're not doing the
right behavior so even with like like a
black bear they play dead it's
don't play don't play dead with a black
bear because they're going to
investigate they want to figure out like
okay
easy you know easy meal they're they're
they're curious and they're gonna go
mess with you
um so what what these rituals did was
they gave
young people who hadn't had the
experience yet an opportunity to see
those scripts in action
then before they may have ever
interacted with the animal they may be
asked
to play out that script take the place
of the bear wear the mask
and and it gives you so acting out the
script of the other person
gives you a better sense of or in this
case the animal
gives you a better sense of what it's
like to be that animal so
um in that case like acting out those
scripts that other people may be using
or
you know other other other actors would
be using um
you know actually is an advantage in the
environment um
on you brought up the throne though and
it's like
yeah it's it's uh um well i like i like
the presentation of it as a mask for a
chair
um but uh uh it's it's really important
in denoting
the person who sits in this chair should
be acting a certain way
right and and when they don't it's a
joke right so i don't know
i was just thinking about like a few
things there there's uh
it's almost like there's a um a real
advantage
to understanding and then acting out the
scripts of others
nice rj the hero with a thousand shares
as it were um i also didn't bring up
wolves and i wasn't praised for that so
exactly oh wait blue so
just kind of thinking about like the
chair itself is actually
like supposed to act a certain way like
you're supposed to do certain things
with the chair
right and and i mean i'm always telling
my kids like
that's for sitting you've got the wrong
end of you on the chair like so
people get creative right like with the
different roles that sure can play it
can be like a step stool or it can be
you know some piece of gymnastic
equipment and it's just it's just
interesting to think about
changing the script even for a chair let
alone the person that's sitting in the
chairs
yeah it's like the setup for an improv
scene
and yeah the different kinds of chairs
are going to lend themselves to
different
scenes maybe with a throne maybe they
could enact a classical
monarchy script or maybe it's a monty
python it's a satire
or with certain kinds of chairs or in
certain context you can enact a chivalry
script and you can pull the chair out
for your colleague
so there's all kinds of ways that um
different props
facilitate or enable different scripts
to play out
and you can always do a mime like you
can sort of act out
a digging or you can act out playing
baseball
but you do need the props or extended
cognition
to actually do some of these scripts
that involve our extended niche
sasha um i just wanted to touch on
something steven said
uh that you said today we don't do much
with masks
um i i guess i would disagree because it
seems like uh a lot of us are doing
a lot with masks and um it's just
yeah kind of obvious to think that um
that's a prop that is gonna change our
behavior
in ways we might not even recognize and
um
yeah just important to think about um
how this uh new prop is changing
human interaction and scripts and
behavior in ways that we don't want or
really expect
a mask to change blue
so sasha didn't come right out and say
it but i'm gonna like maybe
point it at what you're saying maybe not
maybe i took it out of context but
um i think that we do do a lot with
masks like we
are right now using the biggest mask
ever like people are totally different
in like their online persona like some
people will hide behind
a computer screen and act in ways that
they would never ever
behave in real life right so they have
this like mask up they can create this
new persona
and and go forward in the world with
that
yep very true and with new props
there's new scripts there's the one
person's wearing a mask but the other
one isn't script
there's the is that person wearing an
n95 script there's all these things that
wouldn't have even made sense in 2019 so
that's the sense making and the cultural
sense making
and the tension and the friction when
there's
differences on opinion or differences in
behavior and it's about
not just estimates of state but actually
uncertainty
and estimates about other people's
uncertainty that's this whole like
recursive and
embedded element of active inference and
it's about navigating the uncertainty of
a situation not just maximizing
the state itself and that's something
we'll return to for sure stephen
yeah i think this is interesting when
you start to put the mask so this
i suppose i was talking about you know
playing with the mask physically within
the proximity of your face but yeah
there's
there's this kind of mask out there but
it in some ways it's become abstracted
and um like it's it's almost
like you can you put it on and put it
off it's it's it's sort of almost
part of the ecosystem that we've kind of
created which is
maybe a little bit unhealthy because we
don't um
there's actually one really interesting
activity i did once was a chat from
rwanda who
does healing work and he would get you
to put a mask on in front of your face
and read a poem that was really personal
and then you had to lower the mask but
it was like you were lowering the whole
of your
sort of masking identity and it left you
feeling this incredible rawness
which is really interesting so i suppose
um
yeah there is this tendency now that and
i think even maybe more since the 1980s
if i look back at videos of people in
the 80s on tv and that they're often a
lot more
nervous in front of the camera and now
people are used to putting up a
some sort of smiley face type of thing
and presenting and i think there's um
there's something quite interesting in
that that might relate to this paper
yeah i've been thinking about that too
like with the
selfie new affordance of being able to
add an arm's length
look back not just with a disposable
camera and snap the pick
and have the perspectival imagination of
being at your arm's end
but actually seeing it in real time and
then video chatting
or live streaming where you can see your
own face during an interaction
so it's like you're seeing the mask in
real time
and then that's sort of like um i think
it's a campbell quote it could be
someone else but like
if you think that you're rejecting the
mask that society gives you you're just
wearing the mask of rejection everybody
can see that
it's not exactly the quote but basically
it's like you can't not
play the mask game there has to be an
epithelium there has to be a facade
there has to be an interface and so
we're talking about designing that
interface because somebody who goes
around saying
no this is me this is me i have no mask
this is just what i am it's like
right but there still is an external
layer that's being presented right
and if someone says no i'm all me
there's no external level it's like
whoa big of true of course but then it
it's not a helpful viewpoint for the
world because we do
need to interface we need to send
emotions reliably and receive emotions
reliably and so
um a lot there let's continue with some
of these fun questions
so the third question is um
how do the network relationships the red
nodes
influence potentially indirectly the
focal edges in the network blue
and then the fourth question would be
like a little bit more of a wild card
what could be a fun or interesting
social experiment related to active
inference
whether it's something that we do like a
little
experiment or just daily routine tweak
or whether this is something that could
be carried out with a larger scale
laboratory online or in a social setting
um
so either these questions people could
raise their hand on i would uh
start with that third one and uh
highlight that that edge it's a relation
but it's like an atom in the world of
relational thinking
the edge is like the atom and so now
we're in
this network of edges which is what
makes it kind of a tapestry and a social
fabric
and so if we want to understand the
relationship between person a and b
then we're always invoking all the other
edges that stabilize them
whether it's the who brings the food to
these different people or
how do they get their internet because
they're not going to be able to connect
if they're not going to get their
internet and
what are the norms that they're getting
the other 23
hours of the day and that's what shapes
and in some ways can even define the
focal relationship
is again the other 95 of the person's
life or a day
that they're not in that relationship um
during rj all right so um
uh i'm just turning hand off there we go
uh so on the last question i think i
have
um something i've been thinking about
that may relate to the prior one on
network relationships
um so uh
uh my dog achilles uh he usually
wakes me up in the morning uh for for
like the last year or so
uh we we go on a walk at like 5 a.m
um and he is usually raring ready to go
on that walk so
i never really had to worry about an
alarm clock he always you know he would
always pawn me awake
um and if i like there's no snooze
button
on a dog it is you know he he's there
until i wake up
um but recently after thanksgiving um
so i have achilles and my parents have
his brother socrates
and socrates has been staying with us so
now socrates plays with him during the
day where's in the hell out
and uh ever since thanksgiving um
he doesn't wake up in the morning
anymore he doesn't want to wake up he
wants to sleep in
so he had a script that was present in
the morning
that he now no longer has and this has
led to me
over sleeping almost every day because
i'm not i don't have any script
for her for interacting with an alarm
clock in the morning anymore
uh so uh one i think that uh check
you know going right back to the
beginning of like what is not a script
and and where's the transparency on like
on being able to look at
look at what these things actually look
like i think um
our wake up uh scripts are are probably
some of the most transparent because
they're the most consistent
um and they're the most um uh you know
kind of there's not a lot of
uh outside interaction with those
scripts it's it's it's uh very much
like at the moment when you're waking up
becoming conscious in the world
so there's not a lot of priors of them
maybe your dreams et cetera um
so i think it would be kind of a fun
experiment to
to have people try to identify what it
is their morning script actually
is um identify where their first
network relationship is in that script
right because maybe it's
i know some people who wake up and
immediately go on their phone um
uh or you know like so so then um
uh try to see if they can't pick out one
part of that script that's not good for
them that they don't like that's that's
not healthy
um etcetera and then like you know
bringing back to my question
which i wanted to resolve last last week
was
how do you identify the threshold events
where you're able to change scripts
i think it would be a fun experiment to
try to figure out like like what are the
best methods for changing your morning
scripts which are definitely some of the
most difficult to change
good questions rj thank you that um
reminds me of
somebody being asked what is your
morning routine or what's your bedtime
routine and
i'm just projecting but a common
response could be i don't have a morning
routine
it's like well surely you do have a
probabilistic distribution of places you
wake up and
how often you brush your teeth even if
it's zero percent but there's some
distribution of routines
that's the script it could be a weak
script it could be a strong script but
some people just
brush off the question no i don't have a
mask i don't have a routine
it's like a way of not engaging with
that but once you recognize that it's
about the interface and it can be a
probabilistic interface
just to say a morning routine it doesn't
need to be regimented it doesn't need to
be
externalist it also doesn't need to be
internalist
we're moving beyond internalism and
externalism
as well as beyond um restrictive
strong or loose weak we're taking all of
those possibilities
and now we're just thinking yes so what
is your morning script set or maybe what
what genre
are your mornings um is it an emergency
movie
is it a comedy and then also this
question about the dependencies and to
take it back to the social network and
the scripts
it's like we often don't know all the
dependencies until we do a perturbation
so like rj you didn't know about your
lack of an alarm clock
you know stimuli or script until there
was another script that changed in a
non-human
animal and then that had a cascading
failure in this network of dependent
scripts
so it revealed new relationships and
dependencies because of a manipulation
and so that's very related to active
inference on a few levels just to
provide one
is we're always interested not just in
coming to clarity on
world states but actually coming to
clarity on
which interventions or which experiments
or perturbations
would maximally inform us while also
remaining functional
about those dependencies so then you
could be um you know even when a dog was
still waking up early you could have
been experimenting with earlier later
wake ups
and maybe by bumping things by half an
hour this way or another
you would have discovered oh wait
without the dog i don't have a way to
wake up
or if the dog is tired then there's this
other relationship and
nobody would connect the dog being tired
to waking up early for
most people especially if they don't
have a dog but in this case it could
have been explored or actively inferred
with um rightful experimentation sasha
um yeah that's really kind of funny
about the morning routine
because um yeah we of course all have
one but maybe it's uh
not not very glamorous or uh effective
and it just reminds me of um these sort
of
uh glamorized morning routines of
celebrities where like
they spend um you know all this time
putting stuff on their face
essentially and it kind of signals like
i have the kind of morning routine that
i'm proud to tell other people about or
should be uh you know a sensational
youtube video
that other people envy um and so
kind of changing yeah what a morning
routine
is or should be and then also uh part of
that whole like
um kind of uh
thinking about your morning routine is
that it's very solitary when in fact
of course we wake up for other people or
other creatures
and that um we kind of get sucked into
someone else's script
even before we know that we're part of
it um
like people who wake up to take care of
their kids like
maybe they don't want to be waking up
but you know um and then
how to use active inference in a way
that um
helps people modify their um morning
script um in a way that
i i guess it just kind of reminds me of
like biohacking and
and um being very like uh focused on
every metric that you have
so do you have to have all those
metrics in order then to change your
morning
script or like to optimize that or is
there a way where active inference can
help us get around that
kind of self-measurement obsession that
biohacking can veer off into when it can
be more focused on
just uh yeah the the performance and the
human script that we're participating in
good question there sasha and it reminds
me of just the
imperatives in active inference being to
reduce uncertainty and to design optimal
experimentation
and so instead of um in this reward
framework thinking we're going to have
the most rewarding morning
thing it's gonna set you up for the most
productive day or it's gonna feel the
best
it's all about optimization most most
most and here
we're actually saying yeah maybe we'll
get there that'd be great but
just where we are how could we reduce
our uncertainty like maybe every morning
you wake up and you're not sure whether
you're going to take
mechanism a of commute or b so how could
we start by
reducing uncertainty and decreasing
anxiety about the coming day increasing
clarity
and then asking not what is the optimal
state but what's the optimal experiment
and policy that's within
our scope of affordances not like waking
up and instantly going to the strange
attractor of thinking that
something could be a different way um we
can focus on our
policies and then this beyond
internalism and externalism it's just so
critical
because it's uh sort of the false
dialectic of like
worrying about oneself only and then
disregarding systemic issues
versus getting extremely obsessed with
systemic issues
and then losing the site over the
affordances that we do have
and in the middle um is the compromised
language but we're going to not just be
in the middle we're going to be all over
the map
and we're going to be able to dive into
the internalist thinking when we need it
we're going to be diving into the
external thinking when we need it
but we're always going to be able to
return to the fullness of the niche and
what's possible
and getting other people's perspectives
on the issue so that's i think a
marked difference in active inference um
let's uh go on to the next slide
so this one's just kind of a little fun
single question
i was just wondering what does a script
look like and so
the movie script this is the lethal
weapon for autographed edition
script um one of a kind
that's a movie script so the words are
syntactically encoded and maybe the
semantics are suggested
or it gives stage directions like a
dramatic script
and then in the middle is this like peer
pressure script like what's the script
that keeps
people driving on the right side of the
road in america and on the left side of
the road in the uk
that is something that's enforced by
semiotic cues like signs
and um counterfactuals like if i were to
drive
on the other side of the road i would be
in the
felony script something like that but
how does peer pressure play out and how
do we visualize it and then just
a big unknown is what do these active
inference scripts
look like how do we communicate the
scripts
and so instead of um using a movie
dialogue
to convey some of these probabilistic
things or the peer pressure
um narrative to talk about some of these
things
is there another visualization or
representation
just i'm not sure if anyone has thoughts
yeah rj or
and then anyone else go ahead uh well i
i think um
uh i i don't know if um i'm pretty sure
i'm pretty sure the graphic
was in was in the um was in the slides
uh last time
was like uh kind of you know just just
uh you know
2d representation of the axis of like
strong script to weak script and
journalist
externalist and um you know the paper
itself like
like tried to show that it's like look
these these are just um
you know these don't have to be
divergent views they're just
different perspective yeah that's it yep
um and i feel like
uh you know the the actors script is
just a
it's a continuum it's a very strong
externalist script
you're either performing the script
exactly or it's not it's not it's not
being performed it's not happening
um then you have like i brought up
always sunny last time it's like
it's a show that allows for a lot more
improvisation so the scripts they use
while strong and externalist are aren't
as strong as say lethal weapon
right um but then peer pressure is
something that that's that's
far more internalists your your
interpretation of what you think the
script is
and maybe talking with people about what
you think the script is and trying to
work that out
and it's a weak script where it's like
you can even see there that like in
in the picture that it's like not
everybody is is
acting out the same exact script
and like you know like not the same
exact movements whereas you look at
something like
um you know uh opposite end of of the
the
um the the political representation may
be represented as like
you know um uh or or i'm trying to think
like historically
uh like like um uh you know
during during the third reich it's like
these were mixes
of um of internalist scripts of what you
think you're supposed to be acting out
but then there's
also these strong scripts involved where
it's like you are supposed to make
exactly these motions etc great
points there and yes the peer pressure i
put it up there partially because
it so directly calls us to move beyond
internalism and externalism i mean
what could be more external than other
people
yet at the same time what could be more
internal
psychologically or neurophysiologically
than your interpretation of
peer pressure and then on the strong
versus weak just like you brought up
um what could be weaker than an
invisible
and lightly guiding force in some cases
like
hey peer pressure is like you should
wear uh shoes that have tied laces but
no one's gonna like freak out
but there's other peer pressure things
that people will freak out and that's a
strong script
if 100 of the time that something
happens socially enacted
another thing happens it's quite strong
because 100 of the time from state a it
moves to state b
mediated by an external force so that's
strong and external
but there's other cases where it's weak
and internal at least
in how it appears and again the goal of
active inference isn't to be like
yep we judge strong versus weak and it's
strong
it's rather to see this continuum
as um an area of theoretical dispute
yes but now just a parameter in
our way of thinking about the world so
that there can be sub-components
or different people in the same crowd
who are experiencing very
different realities or having very
different um
sort of generative statistics for their
decision making based upon
some of these features we're discussing
but yeah very
interesting any other thoughts on the
visualization otherwise there's um
there's more we'll talk to because um
it'll be good to have time for these two
figures is that good
all right let's go to these um two
figures
in the last half hour and just
start out with just what are they
showing
because especially for those on the
social sciences side
it might be like whoa interesting
conversation about the scripts and the
chair and the being and the becoming
but what are these variables and circles
and lines so
let's think about making that bridge
between the qualitative things and the
experiential and the social that we've
been discussing
with a more mathematical way that we're
going to be returning to in all these
different conversations
so and as always people can just raise
their hand but we're going to do
maybe 10 to 15 minutes on each of these
two figures
so figure one in this paper is a simple
generative model for policy selection
and in act imp policy is always pi
p for policy so this is what is being
estimated
the schematic depicts a generative model
for policy selection
it represents probabilistic beliefs
about and then all of this
is color coded so the first thing is
a a is a probabilistic belief
about how observations are related to
the states that cause them so here's
observations this is like
red photon on my retina and this state
is like
i'm wearing a red shirt okay so then
there's this mapping in this case it's
pretty simple
where if there's a red shirt and the
lights are on then
i'm gonna get red photons on my retina
but one could imagine that there's state
estimates that are social
like this person is unhappy with me and
there's some probability mapping onto
different observations of body language
or of um words for example so that's the
a
matrix it links the state estimates of
the world to observations
and a happens instantaneously in time
now b is where we start taking lateral
moves
and this diagram goes from the left
initial conditions
to the right through the time steps one
two three this is discrete time
and b moving us from left to the right
is mapping states onto each other so
if we were talking about the red shirt
well if you're wearing a red shirt at
one moment
basically 100 of the time you're wearing
a red shirt the next moment so that's
one simple format
or it could be again social like given
my estimates of this person
what do i estimate the transition matrix
is
so knowing this person they get unhappy
really fast
but it's really easy to bring them back
to being happy or
they're always happy but once they get
unhappy they're going to stay in that
state for a while
so you can imagine like a matrix where
the on and off diagonals are different
values
and that captures whether once somebody
is in a certain state is it an
attractor state or a dwell state is it a
state that they
evacuate very rapidly like balancing on
one foot
so that's what's captured in this b
matrix is how things change through time
d is the initial conditions so those are
states prior to sampling the world
so that's like when we start having a
conversation
i am estimating your initial con
conditions for that conversation um it's
not that i know nothing about you i'm
bringing in my estimate of before
the conversation before i started
sampling in this epoch
where were you at and then in
the top we have g which includes c
which is the preferences in the outcome
matrices and so g
that's definitely um uh unpacking
equations for another day
for 11 as well as for other discussions
but let's just clarify this
upper half g bears on the selection of
policy
that's why in active inference we're so
obsessed with free energy and how it
relates to control theory
cybernetics policy selection because all
of the coolness of free energy
is that it's a different way of thinking
about how policy selection occurs
so that's why g has an arrow pointing
down to pi
now pi is influencing only
b's so this is what's pretty interesting
is
what is being estimated by the agent is
like this whole
graph okay but the connections within
the model
that are relevant are not from policy to
state
so it's not saying how will states be
different as a function of me with this
investing strategy
or of me with this social strategy or me
with this navigation
strategy how will the states be
different actually it's
policy to state transition matrices
so this is like saying if i undertake a
policy where i exercise every day
then i believe that the state transition
matrix
from being unhealthy to being healthy
will be modified
not that i will move from unhealthy to
healthy that's the state estimator
that'd be policy to state
and it does result in the same
conclusion functionally
but it's actually very very different
from a mathematical
and from a programmatic standpoint to
say that the policy estimate bears on
how states transition into each other
not just at the first level of what the
states will be
so again i can do policy one two three
four five
and instead of saying well if i do
policy one then i would estimate that
this state is most likely and if i do
policy two
this state is most likely that's the old
way of thinking
the b matrix way of thinking is under
policy one
the world is apt to change in this way
under policy two the world is apt to
change in this way
and then that is related back to
affordances and preferences
in the c matrix as well as other
components of g that include for like
the curiosity and the maintenance
of rewarding states and all these other
features so what this graph is showing
again just to sort of close out this
little
section is we're unpacking this idea of
policy selection so just like if we were
picking out how to drive from point a to
point b
we're unpacking this policy selection
with an eye towards
social interactions so where the state
estimates are like
whether the person is happy or unhappy
with me what are the observations i'm
going to see
and how do those get mapped to each
other what is their state through time
or my state their time
and then how does that change what were
the initial conditions that set up the
first observation we got
and then as a function of a lot of cool
stuff the sort of bulk of the iceberg
in g how can policies be selected
to shape the way that states transition
to each other
in a way that's most aligned with how i
want the world to be
and then agents that succeed and not
succeed in those that don't
don't so i hope that that sort of
conveyed some of the
attributes of this graph any thoughts or
questions or what what's another context
where this graph could be
sort of lifted up and placed down upon
yeah so while people are thinking and
raising
their hand um again
i would just try to give one more bridge
to the
onboarding to active inference side
because for those who are familiar with
the formalism
this is not even the full formalism
they've probably
already seen more expanded versions but
for those
for whom this type of diagram is
relatively novel
in a social sciences setting just always
keep in mind that no matter
how many letters how many edges
superscript
subscript greek letters you know
cyrillic letters
whatever there is we're trying to just
be specific
about what we're talking about and find
a generalization or structure
that allows us to map structurally
analogies from different social settings
so this could be um so many different
systems will fit under this
type of model as well as and importantly
that strong versus weak internal versus
external
idea that we were talking about earlier
so we can have the initial conditions be
me going outside with no shoes and
here's somebody else estimating
um things about me or me estimating
things about other people
or this could be um the initial
conditions of hamlet
in a given production or this could be
the initial conditions of 2020
and so how in all of those different
areas that qualitatively we were talking
about how scripts could be used
how are we gonna find a sort of uh
skeleton
scaffold that all these other situations
will be able to kind of hang on
in a way that respects the specifics
about their situation
um as well as might even provide us with
new
knowledge so for some of you that might
be hearing it twice the same way in a
row for some of you it might be zero
and maybe for others it's in the middle
any thoughts though before we go to the
next figure which is probably a bit
richer all right let's look at the next
figure so anyways this was the skeleton
generative model so hopefully we just
familiarized ourselves with
the idea that things about social
situations
could be abstracted and represented with
uh
vectors and matrices and policy now
we're going to take that
to and here's in the paper where they
write about
how that could map now let's look at a
little bit more expanded of an example
okay so now we're looking at not just
the agent
but also the agent and the world or what
are called here the internal realizer
and the external realizer
because in figure one we were just
looking
at basically the internalist perspective
we were just looking at you know you
could imagine that a brain were doing
that or a computer were doing that but
there's nothing about the world there's
no
there's an estimate of the world state
but there isn't
an actual world state in this model so
this is purely internal to the agent
now let's look at figure two figure two
is where we're going to start to
bring in the world and we're gonna bring
it in at a very specific position
and that is generating the observations
that's really crucial the world doesn't
intervene
by jumping into the internal model now
it might
in reality this is the
instrumentationalism of active
inferences we're going to model it as if
the only interface that the world could
have
is with observations and so in this
figure one the only inputs to the model
were basically the initial conditions
and then
the observables and now we're picking
right up here at the bottom of the
figure
and we're gonna graft the world in so
here's those observations
and those observations are being
generated by world states
which are 11 so here reading from the
caption
on the side of the external world
there's only one process in play which
is the likelihood of observation states
the world
11 and the transitions between these
states
in nine that's down here okay so
this from the point of view of the agent
is the generative process that's
creating the observations
so like there's a shirt that's
generating the red photons
that is hitting my retina for example
but here's what's really interesting is
this model
of hidden state mapping observation
transition matrix change in state
emittance matrix observation again that
is what we just saw in figure one
flipped 180 degrees state estimate and
transition matrix and then leading to
observations
that is this deep and fundamental
symmetry
that has been explored by axel constant
and yella brunenberg and others
it's this idea that we're gonna do this
mathematical phrasing where like
we know which side we're on we know
which side is the internal side and
which side is enclosed by the epithelium
but mathematically
look at 7 5 8 5 7
and similarly 11 10 9 10 11.
here you just have observation in the
middle
it's on the interface that's like the
retina being hit by the photon
and then there's a mapping on the
internal side
from the agent through some type of
likelihood matrix
to the observations so the agent is like
reading
it's trying to say what is the hidden
state five given
observation so what is the best seven to
estimate five given the observation and
then
what is 8 what's the transition matrix
from 5 to 5
and then similarly for the next time
step and then on the other side it's the
exact same
except the key difference is that in the
case of the internal agents we have six
and so in six we have policy here it's a
flirting policy
but in the world there are things that
change
state to stay in the world but we don't
have policy control we don't have agency
over those states
and so then in order to select policy
we have that g and that's kind of where
we see the similarity to figure
one so um it's just a very interesting
formulation
i'm sure each person is going to see
their own thing in it and let's
you know have some conversation or
questions about
uh what's unclear here but we're setting
up
the world and the agent the heuristic
description of the generative model of
the niche and of the agent
we're setting them up in this
intertwined and uh
inextricable but also deeply symmetrical
way
where if it was an agent who's like an
organism and the niche is the forest
so the forest doesn't enact any strategy
it has a certain layout of acorns but
that's not
a strategy that's like a chair for the
squirrel and then the squirrel is the
active inferring agent that's going to
be doing things in this forest
so we can capture that here but also if
it was
squirrel versus squirrel combat and each
squirrel
was going to be having a generative
model of the other squirrel
having a generative model of it these
are higher
order theory of mind recursive theory of
mind
it would be embedded in recursive
because it'd be like about
other active inference agents in the
world and it could be
deep it could be temporally deep it
could include counter factuals it could
include
affect or valence that's what we'll be
talking about in 11.
but it's set up in this way that's very
parsimonious
because in the limit it allows for a
true symmetry
across the interface across the blanket
in the niche
where the niche can be learning and
making a model of the agent and vice
versa
so in the extreme it allows for that
type of richness of
agent agent dynamics or this could be
reduced to two
inanimate objects so if there's two
rocks that are just you know
two bumps on a log and they're not doing
free energy minimization or recursive
estimation of anything they're just
doing what they're doing with a certain
state transition matrix
that can be captured within a reduced
version of this framework so
yeah not trying to rant on it but i just
think that's kind of an interesting
piece of it
and we often come back to this idea of
niche construction and it's like
wait isn't control theory about what's
the best strategy
where is niche construction coming into
play internalism externalism
it's like we're moving beyond
internalism and externalism
because we're saying you always need
both you're always going to need both
and there's going to be many types of
interfaces
one important interface is seven
and observations which is like the
sensory states the sensory
capacities of the organism the umvelt
and the actual
observations themself that's like the
handshake
or the api call that actually crosses
the interface
those are critical but almost by
definition because if there's something
that doesn't cross the interface
on the inbound side like a sense data
that doesn't hit
a neuron or on the outbound side like an
action that doesn't act
if it doesn't cross the interface and
make the connection it's almost like it
didn't happen
and so we define the interface in terms
of
the connections that do happen and then
we can always be sure to be talking
about relevant features of the world
and always in a way that moves beyond
simple
conceptions of internalist versus
externalist
will have the ability to find situations
where
the internal features given a certain
blanket of analysis
dominate the dynamics of the system or
where given the inclusion of certain
parameters in a certain time scale of
analysis
the external features dominate it but no
one can say that's really
a win for externalism or a win for
internalism
it's just a description of a situation
so um
i think it's an example about how we
move beyond some of these
theoretical um and literature grounded
abstractions with a more
abstract and general framework that
actually lets us be more specific
in the projects so we kind of escape
this uncanny valley of
whose team is better internalism or
externalism
we're going to escape that valley by
taking one step
towards abstraction by like whoa what if
we thought about the agent and the world
as
acting across an interface in the most
general possible way
but it turns out that by framing it as
an interface we're going to be able to
be very very specific
about the narratives of radicalization
or
the kinds of cues that are exchanged in
a flirting relationship
whereas if you're in the debate of
internalism externalism
you could have whole academic
conferences on
narratives of radicalization or
behaviors of flirting
and potentially the people would leave
that meeting still feeling like their
side had won so there wouldn't be a true
conceptual synthesis
so again a little bit another spiral
away another
tangent but that's why these kinds of
formalizations
and specifically graphical and
computable
ways of thinking about them can bring
clarity to some of these long-standing
qualitative questions
and also necessitate the collaboration
of basically
quantitative and qualitative expertises
rj
um so so um i've seen like not
exactly this this graphic but but um uh
throughout each of the papers especially
the ones fristen's involved with there's
always some iteration of it
um and some iteration of explanation of
active inference and one thing
um that i've seen alluded to
in the words but not in the graphic is
um this updating of the observation
itself
um and maybe this is being represented
here and i'm not seeing it
um but but what what offend is like um
and and and
i'll i'll get to to why this is uh uh
fairly important to me
uh in a second but but um it seems like
well in any process of sense making we
have this induction
and at the state of induction
uh you're actually like before you're
getting to trying to parse meaning
you're you're trying to like check
whether or not
what you've observed is even the correct
observation so it's the double take
um and and this is one of the reasons in
intelligence analysis
that like collection is separated from
from
from your your all other elements of the
production cycle
because that what they're trying to do
is they're trying to make sure that
there's not this like
constant seduction of going back and
checking again checking again checking
again they're trying to make it so
there's a pipeline so when something
comes in it's going up the pipe it's not
your job to look any further
into whether or not what you saw was
meant something or whether or not it was
correct or
it's just report what you saw push it
through and now it's not your problem
anymore it's
somebody else's problem right um so like
now
at the at at the the scale of the
individual though
uh we're constantly double checking
ourselves whether or not we we saw
we thought we saw so like if i'm if i'm
reading a paper and i find
um you know um something cited and and
and
i kind of know where that's coming from
so this happened when we
were a few people on this call we were
working together on on a paper for
active influence and behavioral
engineering
and i was looking into a spirit decor
and while i was doing that
there's a big problem because there were
so many different interpretations of
what a spirit decor meant
so so what ended up happening is every
time i saw the words i'm checking myself
and going wait is am i actually
observing what i think i'm observing i'm
checking against priors
and i'm updating my observation um so
what what i'm kind of wondering is like
um one like
is this representing this graphic and
i'm not seeing it uh and then two
um i know that over time we're starting
to see okay like actual computational
models
um using active inference are those
like if they were applied in an agent
based model or applied in machine
learning
are those models trying to act that
process out of like
checking back on the observation and
making sure that it's actually
observing what it thinks it's observing
rather than just taking data in
does that make sense yep thanks for the
question rj
so it is lightly indicated in this
figure
as with the other figure there's a
movement from left to right
okay so the nodes are numbered by the
kind of things that they are
and so it's lightly indicated where the
direction of time is going with these
dotted arrows so like for example the
first
10 on the bottom left that's like a
hidden state of the world
right and through an 11 it emits an
observation at time point 1.
then there's a transition matrix 9
and so if you did hourly checkpoints the
9 matrix that you calculate is going to
be the hourly transition matrix
if you do one minute checkpoints like a
discrete time with an interval of one
nine is going to be a different matrix
so it's kind of like how the the candle
chart of a stock or a crypto looks
different depending on what time length
the candle is so
it's not the same matrix for all time
intervals it's always model
interval dependent but 9 moves us from
the
left 10 to the right 10 and then at that
again it's the type 10 not like node
number 10. it emits
through the same or a different 11
another observation
now the early models all the 11s were
fixed
so like the hidden state could go from
daytime to night time but like the 11
was fixed
and then you could imagine that a more
advanced version of the model would be
like
yeah actually the hidden state through
time
it changes in how it emits 11. okay now
flip the interface seven is perceiving
the observation the left seven and then
it's doing
estimation of the hidden state s so that
or five it just looks like an s and it
is
s in the models so it's kind of like at
each time point we have this like
10 hidden state of the world emits
through 11 in observation that's on the
interface that's that holographic
boundary that chris fields is going to
help us understand
then on the organism side the
internalist side
seven does a state estimate five then
we move through time the organism
updates its estimate through time
with eight and the world updates its
actual state
with nine its hidden state and then
there's another time point another stack
of that
and so in the example that you gave with
like going back and double checking
information
it's like you get an observation at one
moment
and then whether or not it's concordant
with um something
at least you're instantaneously sure of
what it is but then
here's another dimension that the
computational models are going into
which is at each time point it
calculates
an integral through time of policy
so that's the part where we're going to
talk about it in 11 and a few other ones
but the simplest model would be like
again red shirt or you know
black shirt and then it's like the
photon is the observation and the state
estimates pretty straightforward it's
like a two by two matrix
there's an unchanging characters in the
matrix because the red shirt always
emits red and there's no ambiguity okay
now we can start to relax those
assumptions
and we can think about okay maybe
there's more ambiguity in the signal
maybe there's a non-stationary 11 matrix
maybe we can learn seven we can learn
better about how observations are
related to world states maybe we can
learn
eight better which is sort of like uh
trying to reflect
nine we can learn about how states in
the world transition
better and we can learn better policies
too better sixes
but that what we've just been focused on
is really just the loop
with the 10 9 10 9 in the world
5 8 5 8 in the agent and then this
interface
that has a symmetry of the sevens and
the 11's around the observation
itself so yes they're the kinds of
things that people are
starting to roll out but i think that
especially if you watch
11 coming up you'll get a sense at how
rudimentary these roll outs are
really it's at like the uh ibm chess
1995 status where like
many many branches of counterfactuals
are being processed
and then evaluated and more modern chess
computers don't use this branch
rollout evaluation strategy in the same
way
so we're still in a very early stage
that's basically defining what that
rollout would be through time and then
there will be other ways of
heuristically approximating
very good rollouts
sasha
yeah nice thanks for walking through
that on the diagram
uh with all the numbers um yeah uh
just some things that rj reminded me of
um is
in thinking about data collection uh
it would be great if we could separate
um the data collection from the data
interpretation and acting on it and
um you know informalized uh kind of
scientific approaches we
can do that like um i'm just thinking
about my own work when i do
microscopy and i'm looking at some cells
under a microscope and i might have like
an emotional reaction to how they look
which is like they look really good
and i want to analyze them or something
went terribly wrong and they look like
um not even cells at this point
so um i think part of
going through this process is being able
to separate the individual
steps so i have to actively prevent
myself from
uh yeah
uh kind of throwing in the towel
preemptively when i don't
uh that when the data doesn't meet my
expectations
until i go to the next step of like
randomizing and analyzing it
such that i can remove my expectations
um
and just try to collect what is there
and i think that yeah that's something
that's nearly impossible
to do in the human experience that we
can't really separate
um the data collection from the data
interpretation
and um yeah it just moves too fast
and then in the um realm of like
uncertainty and
um yeah what does this word mean in
different contexts as rj was saying
that is the kind of thing that um in
teaching
like uh we try to think you know if you
don't know every single word
in what we're learning today it's going
to be really hard to build on any next
level concepts
so and students will often say like well
i don't really know this word so
i don't know but the first thing to do
is to like
just look up what the word means so that
you can move past that uncertainty and
move on to
move on to the next layers of things um
and so that really to me makes me think
of like social anxiety
and people not being able to interpret
social cues
appropriately and that creating
uncertainty which is just like it kind
of snowballs
once you're uncertain about one aspect
of an interaction or a script
you kind of are prevented from
participating in the next levels or
carrying out the script and so that
perhaps is something interesting to
discuss um in next week's interact
uh discussions cool
thanks i think that question especially
sasha really makes me think about like
script design and we're talking about
the analysis and the descriptive ways of
talking about systems but also about
designing the scene and the stage
i think steven dropped off but is
somebody with
uh drama experience performance
experience
you know social performance performing
our roles
a lot of these terms are starting to
blend with the mask and previously that
would be seen as dramatic or ritualized
now it's seen as a matter of public
safety
so many of these things are actually
coming together in a way where
we can um certainly within our own
life if not at a higher level ask about
what kind of scripts we want to design
for moving forward especially about the
uncertainty from all these different
issues
so um here's just a couple questions i
wanted to throw up we only have you know
three minutes
so really just for the listeners live or
in replay
to add comments or start a discussion
in whatever platform we're using just
questions like thinking about how this
could be a unifying
topic how could this be a valuable model
what unique insights are we looking for
how could we
rethink our experiences what would be
explanations or predictions and what
would be
next steps for the research and um
thanks for participating i'm gonna just
pause it for um
on this final slide as we
hear our last thoughts so everyone
prepare a little last thought if you'd
like
and to listeners thanks for listening we
will have follow-up forms for the live
participants it's in the calendar
invite and anyone is welcome to provide
us with
feedback and stay in touch but for the
last three minutes let's just hear
from our panelists anybody who would
like to what is a last thought
what's something you're still wondering
about or now that we're done with 10
where does that leave us what are some
last thoughts rj and then
blue so we
i think we we did find some conclusion
on um what can't
use a script um but uh
i still don't feel like we have a good
conclusion on what a script isn't what
is that line
so i'm going to be thinking about that
the next week and
i hope we we touch on that next
discussion
awesome blue so i'm just wondering
left really wondering where can we use
this
to engineer social behavior or to change
scripts that are perhaps
unnecessary or unwanted in society like
radicalization scripts or or things like
that so that's where i'm left
you know how do we then go out and apply
what we've learned
cool um either of the sashas or yvonne
um yeah i similar to blue i'm left
thinking about what is the application
of active inference in scripts and um
i guess in instead of feeling uh
unsatisfied i feel
excited about it that's my perspective
that it seems that maybe at the end of
the last conversation
i felt uh ambivalent or confused about
scripts and now i'm a bit more uh
directed in their their use or their
possibilities so i'm i'm really
happy to kind of have uh talk through
this
and uh find a way out
that makes me feel excited about scripts
that hold
space specifically for things like
freedom of expression or speech or
improvisation
it's like um a protection within the
script this is the part of the song
where there's a drum solo
so for this part you get to play in time
and then for this part
it gets to be wacky and so in that
way we can um and like blue is saying as
well with the design
we could be able to converge on scripts
that protect
certain freedoms as intrinsic
to the structure of the script and being
able to
have a discussion about that that is um
nuanced like we hopefully are
representing and learning how to
represent here
that could be a really productive
discussion instead of just about
rights versus um all these other things
that can get tangled down in
so everybody thanks so much for
participating
and for the great discussion as always
this is it for 10
we will have 11 in the final two weeks
of december
2020 the 11th hour the 11th active
stream
and then we will have 12 the clock will
strike midnight
on active 2020 and we will be heading
into a very exciting
2021. so thanks again for listening and
for participating
and see you later